so as we get into the conclusion of the
house of M what we do here is we pick up
with Leila Miller Emma Frost and cloak
and what's basically happened here is
that the forces of the awakened
superheroes have split into three groups
the first group is the group that we saw
that attacked the grand celebration gala
of magneto the second group is what we
see here with Emma Frost Leila Miller
and cloak and the third group is
actually just one person and that's
Doctor Strange and what we find with
Emma Frost and cloak and Leila Miller is
that their goal is to find Charles
Xavier
but when they actually enter the area
where they believe Charles Xavier is
most apt to be they find that there's
really just a I guess the memorial of
sorts here and so this confirms Emma
Frost's worst fears and the belief that
Charles Xavier is dead here the Charles
Xavier is been dead and this entire
reality and so what happens is cloak
actually travels below the surface of
this grave and when he goes under when
he goes to the bottom what he does is he
comes back and he tells Emma Frost that
there's no body there that there's no
burial no no remains or anything that
they're simply just ground or simply
just grass and that Charles Xavier
doesn't actually appear to be there
indicating the Charles Xavier may not
actually be dead and so what we do here
is we jump back to the conflict with
regards to the other awakened
superheroes and this grand celebration
gala and what we find here with this
conflict is that of course storm is
pleading with these other superheroes
asking why it is that they're attacking
them and so on and we have Cyclops
telling her that that I'm sorry
Wolverine telling her that they've been
friends for quite some time that they
are for the most part a rose family and
so while she doesn't realize it yet
they're actually here to benefit her and
so again as we continue with this what
we do is we pick up with Doctor Strange
and Doctor Strange has managed to
infiltrate the location of where the
Scarlet Witch is at and she's simply
playing with her children and so again
as they continue to talk as they
continue to discuss it seems as though
the skull at which again knows who dr.
strange is and the initial thought here
is that the Scarlet Witch remembers
changing everything she remembers how
things are supposed to be most likely
with the exception of Leila Miller and
Wolverine she is the only other person
who knew how things were before Leila
Miller and Wolverine started waking
everybody up but what happens here is
that as the two of them continue to
converse and what we learn is that this
may not necessarily be the case with a
very least the Scarlet Witch is simply
just referring to some point in time
that may not have happened and the
reason why is because dr. strange asks
her if she knows who he is and she says
of course she says that he had been
there for the birth of her children and
so again what this does is tell us that
either she somehow becomes so obsessed
with this reality that she believes it's
real and she's simply ignoring the
previous reality because as far as she's
concerned it doesn't exist anymore
or it could just be that she really does
genuinely believe this is the real
reality but again what she tells dr.
strange is that the I guess the physical
body of her self that had dissipated out
in on the battlefield was not her actual
body that in fact she never actually
leaves the confines of where her
children are at and again what dr.
strange says here is that he believes
that the Scarlet Witch was the one that
had basically given them an out he's the
war she's the one that had basically
created Leila Miller as a way to bring
all these superheroes here but what the
Scarlet Witch says is she doesn't know
who Leila Miller is and so what we do is
we continue with this discussion is that
again we see Doctor Strange telling her
that there are various people here that
her friends are fighting on behalf of
her they're fighting for what they
believe to be a way to change this
reality back and they're doing it
outside and the Scarlet Witch seems
genuinely surprised by this because what
she does is she actually opens a wall
and when she looks outside the wall she
sees that there's of course that's
really huge conflict taking place and so
she seems disappointed here she seems
disheartened and the reason why is
because a Scarlet Witch explains it to
us the entire purpose of this reality
was to simply have a reality where
everyone had what they wanted where
everybody had no reason to fight but
that in the end it ultimately broke down
into fighting anyway and this is very
important because what this is going to
do is tie into the last thing that she
does before she sets everything back but
again what uh what dr. strange asks here
is whether or not she had I guess
whether or not her father whether or not
magneto had put her up to doing this and
again he asked her where is Charles
Xavier and so what happens
is she says that it's a lot more
complicated than dr. strange is making
it out to be that it's a lot more
difficult than he's making it out to be
and so what she does is she shows him
the events that had taken place before
we had seen the reality switch and what
happened here was that after the
discussion between Magneto and
Quicksilver where they were yelling at
one another that it appears that
Quicksilver didn't actually leave and
that magneto was the one who had left
and so Scarlet Witch began talking with
with Quicksilver and what she basically
tells him is that she realizes that her
friends are coming for her but that in
the end she deserves it that because of
her actions that she believes something
needs to be done and this may very well
be the kind of thing that needs to take
place but Quicksilver doesn't want to
believe it Quicksilver says that he's
not going to let the Avengers and the
x-men kill her that he will take her
away from this place and if he needs to
he will fight all of them to keep her
alive but again what she says is that as
far as she's concerned she didn't really
believe they had a chance that is to say
that her and Quicksilver never really
had a chance to live a proper life that
ever since there were children all they
had known was conflict and the first
time they had come into contact with
Magneto they had been immediately
adopted into his Brotherhood of Evil
Mutants and had been used for Magneto's
own schemes and so as things continue
again what she says is that they were
supposed to be a family of some kind
that they were supposed to be able to
function together they should have had a
proper life but instead they didn't get
that and that if she could she would do
anything to take it back and so what
Quicksilver says here is that she could
if she wanted to and she asked him what
it means and she he says it's entirely
possible that it that the Scarlet Witch
could make everybody happy but the
Scarlet Witch says she can't really
control her powers and Quicksilver says
what if there was someone there to help
her what if he was there to help her
that if he and her together were able to
control her abilities that she could do
the things that she wanted to do and she
can make the world a perfect place and
so again she's very hesitant here but
Quicksilver uses some very persuasive
logic there's a very persuasive language
here and saying that this is the chance
for the skull at which to make everybody
a family this is a chance to have the
life that she said that she was hunting
for and that in the end everything will
be better permanent
and so what happens is that the Scarlet
Witch and Quicksilver seem to basically
vanish they seem to out to teleport away
and then we learned that the entire
basis for why the house of them had
changed or I'm sorry why the house would
become into existence was because
Quicksilver had gotten the Scarlet Witch
to do it and so everybody's assumption
that magneto was the one that was behind
this was entirely wrong and so again
what we do is we see that dr. strange
contacts Emma Frost and as Emma Frost is
she understands or she's heard what's
going on here she's been able to pick up
his information using her telepathic
link and she tells dr. strange that he
needs to ask Emma for I'm sorry I asked
uh Scarlet Witch about Charles Xavier to
ask her if she knows where Charles
Xavier is but as he as a doctor
strangers asking the Scarlet Witch this
question the Scarlet Witch seems to be
struck from behind and when she falls
over we found that there's actually an
arrow in her back and so again what we
do is we see that we switch back to
Layla Miller and Emma Frost as we find
the Magneto approaches and magneto asks
them what it is they're doing here and
why it is that they're bothering his
family but what Layla Miller does is she
seems to panic and so she simply just
wakes up magneto to the events of the
House of M and so what we do is we jump
back to the Scarlet Witch and we find
that clint barton was the one that has
shot her in the back and clint barton is
very very angry here and the reason why
is because when wolverine had met up
with luke cage and his forces he had
told a told clinton Partin had told
hawkeye that he had been killed and the
normal continuity and the scarlet witch
had been the one to do it and so clint
barton had basically lost his sanity
here he couldn't cope with the fact that
if things had gone back to normal that
he would go back to being dead but even
more so than that that the scarlet witch
had betrayed him that a friend had had
basically killed him and so what seems
to happen is that one of her children
gets very very angry here and it seems
at least initially that maybe her child
is the one that attacks a hot guy and
basically begins to disintegrate hawkeye
or to eliminate hawkeye entirely from
this reality but what we find is that a
scarlet witch is talking with dr.
strange as she says she didn't mean to
do it that's that he was so mad at her
and that she just wanted to protect her
children basically acting at
instinct here and so again The Scarlet
Witch begins to continue to break down
continuing to say as she can't really
control any of her power here and so
what seems to happen seems to have
happened with this house of em I guess
world or this reality is that the
Scarlet Witch had created the House of M
reality but then it set itself on its
own course and things continued along
their own way and so what happens is we
jump back to the conflict outside where
where Quicksilver seems to be actually
overpowering all these different
superheroes he's able to move so fast
that he can basically take them all off
guard here but then suddenly we see that
magneto appears and magneto is in a
right state here and the reason why is
because now that he's been woken up with
regards to the whole House of M
continuity he's become aware of the fact
that Quicksilver was the one that had
got the Scarlet Witch to change
everything then that as far as he's
concerned it had been done in his name
and so again the two continue to argue
back and forth Quicksilver and Magneto
continue to yell Quicksilver says that
they were going to kill her that magneto
was going to let it happen
but magneto says that a Quicksilver was
going to that he had basically used the
Scarlet Witch and he had used Magneto
and he had done it in his name and so
again what happens here is magneto
freaks out and in a completely enraged
state and he takes a giant piece of
metal and smashes Quicksilver with it
basically killing him and so what
happens is the Scarlet Witch realizing
what's going on
Liza's leaves the confines of her
children and immediately freezes magneto
in place to where he can't do anything
and she actually takes away his ability
to talk here and so what happens is that
she revives Quicksilver she brings him
back to life and again the question
everybody's asking here is what should
they do and for the most part they don't
really think they should do anything at
the moment the reason being because the
skull at which is basically walking a
knife's edge here her mind is in total
chaos and that she could basically use
her powers to blink them all out of
existence without even realizing that
she had done it and so after reviving
quick so where she begins to turn on
magneto she begins to get very angry
with him and the reason why is because
what she says is that Quicksilver only
wanted my needle to be happy but all of
this had been done in order to make
everybody happy and that she and
Quicksilver had been taken in vain
by Magneto time and time again due to
the fact that magneto has this I guess
inherent drive to somehow find a way to
be better than normal humans and so she
says that even when magneto gets what he
wants even when he gets this perfect
reality that he somehow finds a way to
ruin it and that in the end mutants are
not heroes they're not something some
great concept at they're freaks and so
what she does is she makes us she says
one of the most famous words that were
ever uttered in the history of the x-men
comics and she says no more mutants and
so what we do here is we jump back to
the normal earth-616 continuity and what
happens with this continuity is that we
wait well I'm sorry we start out with
Peter Parker and Peter Parker simply
just wakes up realizing that he's still
married to Mary Jane Watson but what
happens here is that Peter Parker seems
to remember everything he seems to
recall everything that had happened in
the House of M and so what we do is we
transition to the Xavier school for
gifted youngsters and we pick up with
Emma Frost and when Emma Frost begins to
come to she remembers everything but
then she hears people panicking within
the Institute and what happens is she
gets in there she finds various students
all over the place she finds various
students everywhere and they're all
panicking because they've lost their
powers and so what's happening here is
we're seeing that Kitty Pryde that Emma
Frost
that Cyclops that they're all talking
about what had gone on here and that
they recall the Scarlet Witch saying no
more mutants and so what seems to have
actually happened here is that when the
Scarlet Witch had said everything back
that she had taken away mutant powers
from everybody and so as it stands right
now there do not appear to be any
mutants now again we'll find out there
are there are in fact only 198 mutants
left but again we see that as they
continue with this they're trying to
figure out everything that's going on
they're trying to understand everything
that's going on and so what we see is
that Emma Frost runs back to where
cerebra is located and she puts on the
helmet and she begins to scan the planet
and this is when we learned there are
pretty much no mutants left there are
only a handful and this is evidenced by
the fact that we only see several dots
here and there that we only see a few
thousand here and there there I'm sorry
a few hundred here and there that
ultimately as besets speculated that
there were probably tens of
if not possibly millions of mutants in
the world but that there are not anymore
and so what we do is we pick up with the
Scarlet Witch and The Scarlet Witch is
simply just going about her normal
business she seems to simply just be
enjoying the day she seems to be
shopping around she seems to be just
enjoying this experience and it appears
that she's basically human that she's
basically just a normal person and so
what we do is we see that as we're
looking at her as we're seeing her that
there's also an interview taking place
with Hank hem and what Hank Pam is
saying is that this entire concept of
what's going on with mutants is very
very particular that it's very strange
and the reason behind this there the
reason I reason for this strange kind of
concept is because a lot of the powers
that mutants had had manifested
themselves in a physical way the optic
blasts of Cyclops for example but what
what's basin basically taking place is
that if these mutant powers manifest
themselves in a physical way it means
they have physical form they have matter
they exist in some capacity and that
what we know about the laws of physics
is that matter can't simply just
disappear that matter goes from one form
to another and so what he says is that
while they don't necessarily have the
use of their powers that the energy that
would normally be reserved for the use
of their powers had to have gone
somewhere all those powers had to have
been located somewhere and so what
happens is that we begin to zoom out on
the planet earth we begin to move
further and further away and what we
find is that some massive ring begins to
form around the planet earth indicating
to us that this is where all the powers
are at but they're basically just
hovering around the planet Earth with
that being said we're going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys later
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from comics explained and talk
to me directly